in a small village in Europe the people
live in constant fear of a dreadful
Dragon the Beast is known for its
ruthlessness towards humans in order to
appease this Dragon the villagers
sacrifice their young maidens in a
ritual on each occasion the dragon
selects one maiden and abducts her this
ritual continues for years until a brave
knight travels to the dragon's island to
rescue his beloved but when he discovers
that she's already dead he engages in a
fierce battle with the dragon and
defeats it he was hoping that she been
cucking him with the dragon and that he
could join in the Knight ultimately
frees his people from fear and gets
titled as the dragon's Slayer now the
dreaded ritual is transformed into a
wedding ceremony the scene then fast
forwards to many years later when the
young princess miroslava mea for short
is betrothed to the dragon slayer's
grandson Igor her father and sister
think she's immature because she still
likes fairy tales and playing with toys
nonetheless they prepare her for the
wedding before escorting out of the
palace Mera is is placed on a boat deck
which will be sent across the water
towards her future husband as eigor
pulls her boat towards him his people
sing the ancient ritual song in honor of
his grandfather the dragon slayer
suddenly a fierce storm overtakes them
and the dragon who is thought to have
been dead shows up again terrifying
everyone it captures mea from the
ceremony and throws her inside a cave on
a remote island a while later she
regains Consciousness and finds the hole
she'd fallen from she tries climbing up
but a wolf-like creature startles
causing her to fall back down the
creature descends and growls menacingly
prompting Meera to arm herself with a
stone just then she hears a male voice
that urges her to throw the stone away
and lie down the creature then
approaches her but it leaves without
harming her following this Mera asks
about the person's identity and requests
to help her out however the person tells
her that he can't do so leading Mera to
assume that he's also a captive she then
proceeds to inquire more about the place
and the dragon but the person responds
that it's not safe for them to talk and
refuses to explain anything desperate
for Aid mea pounds on the wall and
pleads for help but she eventually
stumbles due to her injuries seeing this
the man offers her a paste made from
crushed leaves for her wounds what it's
not going to do anything leaves don't do
through the hole Mira looks at the
man's face that doesn't look like a
prisoner she then introduces herself but
the man cannot recall his own name as he
never needed it later on Mera devises a
plan to kill the wolf and flee while the
dragon is asleep however the man claims
that they can't escape the Dragon no
matter how much they try mea then calls
him a coward and shuts the hole in Anger
determined to make her way out she cuts
her braided hair and starts making a
makeshift robe during this the man tries
to talk to her saying that he's not a
coward it's just that the dragon is
unbeatable he even apologizes to her
prompting her to remove the Rock from
the hole after this she bestows the name
Armen upon him which she thinks is
exotic and mysterious like him and she
just watched the attack on Titan finale
and it was badass she then extends her
hand for a handshake but as soon as they
touch one another the dragon pulls him
away Armen warns her about the dragon
and asks her to stay hidden soon after
the dragon shows up above Mira which
scares the life out of her after it
leaves Mera tries to call out for Armen
but there's no response maybe this is
more like Attack on Titan than she
thought left alone she tries using her
hair as a rope to climb up but her
efforts proed to be futile frustrated
she grabs a big rock and starts banging
on the wall surprisingly the wall
crumbles revealing a hole big enough for
her to pass through following this she
walks out and heads towards the exit as
she walks through the passway the dragon
begins chasing her in a state of panic
she runs away and enters another hole
the dragon blows fire in the hole but
she manages to slip inside she then
reaches an edge which is much higher
from the ground level before she can
advance further Armen shows up and tries
to stop her to to her astonishment the
wolf obeys his commands and she finally
realizes that he is in fact the dragon
called it Arman tries to calm her down
promising to explain everything but Mera
walks backwards and falls off as she
plummets down through the air Armen
catches her his body glows red and he
turns into the dragon seconds before
they hit the ground he saves her life
but he hits the ground and gets injured
in the process shortly after the dragon
reverts to armen's form assuming it to
be a threat mea considers crushing him
with a talk however she can't bring
herself to do it she feels bad about
armen's condition so she starts helping
him instead she pulls him to an empty
space and eventually collapses beside
him a few moments later the asleep Armen
mutters that the dangerous Dragon Fire
Within him poses a grave threat to
everyone and needs to be taken out right
then his body emits a red glow and
Teeters on the brink of transforming
into a dragon but he collapses once more
after this SMA descends to the Shoreline
and cries out for help but there's no
one to answer her call shortly after she
spots an old boat washed ashore
momentarily raising her hopes of
escaping however she abandons the idea
when a storm hits the sea as a result
she runs back to Armen and uses a broken
ship Mast to create an improvised
shelter once done she again hears Armen
murmuring something seeing that he's
injured she applies the leaf paste to
his wound and bandages it with her
sleeves as she touches him his body
begins to glow red but she calms him
down by singing a lullabi which
surprising Works eventually Mera also
falls asleep beside him she will
complete the prophecy by cucking eigor
with this Dragon the following morning
she wakes up to find herself wrapped in
a blanket and a piece of fruit left by
Armen after eating it she heads down to
the shore where she finds him catching
fish she inquires why he won't simply
take her home if he has no intention of
killing her in response Armen explains
that it's not as simple as it seems he
then proceeds to share his life story
recounting how he never wanted to become
a dragon like his father but a upon
witnessing his father being killed he
was overcome with rage that transformed
him into a dragon despite this tragedy
he vowed to live as a human for this he
isolated himself on the island to
prevent himself from killing humans when
he sensed the uncontrollable transition
to Dragon form he would go into a narrow
cave where the dragon couldn't escape
and remain there until reverting to
human form Armen asserts that everything
was going well until he heard the ritual
song during mea's wedding according to
him the Dragon Inside him awakens every
time she touches him which is the reason
why he can't drop her at home
furthermore he says that the island is
Bewitched so only those who are loved by
someone on the island can find the way
to it in the middle of their
conversation Armen stumbles and Falls
but he warns her not to help him fearing
that the dragon might awaken Mera
assures him that it hasn't emerged yet
and indicates that his true Human Side
is getting stronger she then promises to
teach him how to live as a human while
she awaits Igor's arrival in the next
scene Mera decides to transform armen's
Den into a more human-like place they
worked together on using Shipwrecked
items and washed up stuff to decorate
the space days pass and the two begin to
enjoy each other's company eventually
they succeed in turning the once empty
Den into a beautiful Haven while staying
there Mera presents Armen with a flute
that plays a lullabi tune in return He
surprises her with some fireworks
leaving the girl mesmerized one night
Mera awakens to an unusual sound and
begins searching for Armen soon after
she comes across the dragon and bravely
extends her hand to touch it however
upon contact the dragon becomes
uncontrollable and starts pursuing her
suddenly Mira snaps out revealing that
it was just a nightmarish dream she
finds Armen in front of her visibly
worried she confesses her fear of
dragons to which Armen reassures her
that the dragon will never harm her the
following day Mera swims in a natural
pool while Armen holds some flowers in
his hand it appears that he's
contemplating expressing his love for
her but is too nervous to do so moment
moments later the dragon begins to
possess his body causing the flowers to
burn sensing the transformation he runs
to a cliff and tries to calm himself
down mea soon locates him and shows him
a kite she has made Armen asks for the
reason why Igor hasn't come yet but she
doesn't have an answer it's evident that
she doesn't want him to come as she's
slowly falling in love with Armen later
that night Armen finds a boat on the
shore and assumes that mea is attempting
to escape he then confronts her and
leads her to an altar where her reveals
that the true reason for the dragons
bringing maidens to the island according
to him the dragons burn the young girls
to death and From the Ashes of each girl
a new Dragon is born which is how Armen
was born he warns that the same fate
awaits mea he also claims that he's a
Monster who will never live as humans do
and that it's right for her to fear Him
Armen then says that he has been noting
her actions for several days he believes
that she is collecting washed up items
to examine Maps using fireworks as a
signal and the boat as a means of Escape
he finally orders her to leave the very
next day mea attempts to clarify the
misunderstanding but the enraged Armen
tosses her flute away breaking her heart
early in the morning Meera boards the
boat and sets sail elsewhere eigor and
his men are seen searching for her but
their efforts prove fruitless eigor who
doesn't share the same courage as his
grandfather contemplates turning back
however his Helmsman reminds him of his
oath and prevents him from doing so to
protect the honor of his family name in
other words he says don't be such a
sir in the midst of their dispute
fireworks illuminate the sky and mirror
emerges from the fog they quickly bring
her aboard and inquire about the dragon
to prevent Armen from any harm she lies
that the dragon fell off a cliff and
perished in the next scene we see mea
once again being prepared for her
wedding with Igor although she doesn't
look happy about it on the other hand
Armen is also overwhelmed with sadness
uncertain as to how to continue living
without merera nonetheless he holds
gratitude for the happy moment moments
she left behind he bids her farewell and
heads toward the cliff clutching her
flute in his hand he then jumps off
intending to commit the unthinkable as
Arman plummets through the air his inner
dragon awakens but he manages to sooth
it by playing the flute simultaneously
Mira is placed in a boat and Igor begins
to pull her across the water but in the
Midway she realizes that she still loves
Armen and cannot live without him as a
result she gets up and declares that she
doesn't love Igor taken a back eigor
reminds of how he saved her but Mera
yells that she loves the dragon once you
go D you're not good enough for me
following this she proceeds to sing the
ritual song to summon her love Igor
tries to warn her about the consequences
while her father and sister watch with
tears in their eyes as she completes
singing the dragon shows up and
recaptures mea taking her back to the
island he places her on the altar but
this time she isn't scared she confesses
her love for him which soon melts away
armen's anger he then rests his head on
her lap allowing her to caress him years
later Armen and Mera are seen living
together on the island and they now have
a little daughter after putting their
baby to sleep Mera mounts her Dragon
husband and they take off together
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching